hi welcome to architecting with google
cloud my name is felipe modela how many
times you headed to your favorite or
needed dining spot that you probably
were in a rush for an event which was
about to start or like myself you had
hungry kids running around and just wish
the line wait time wasn't that long i
guess far too often right so what if
there was a way to get in a priority
queue to avoid those long lines and have
a better experience well there is a way
and today i invited grav arberwa he's
the co-founder of sleek to share a
little bit more about its ai and ml
based priority lane solution that
retailers can implement in just one line
of code and consumers like us can enjoy
the shorter wait welcome guerra off to
the show everybody great to be here
thanks for inviting me um
yeah really excited to be here thank you
wow it's our pleasure and it seems last
time
in line sounds like an amazing idea so
tell us a little bit more about sleek
how it works and how this actually idea
came about for you definitely sleek is
about giving you your time back imagine
going to an event um
and not having to wait in line you know
go going to 14 on this game um and not
having to wait in line to get in the
event and getting to your seat getting
your food drink your favorite march or
getting out of the event that is what
you're trying to do the time to
eliminate line anywhere and everywhere
it need not be stadium
it can be in your favorite restaurant or
you're like a salon like any place where
there's a product or services to be sold
and
you can actually get your time back you
know you can just
reserve your slot for your product
service and get back uh when it's your
time or you can pay a premium fee and
take a disney fast pass have a private
service to be like right uh very
interesting so i live in texas and what
if i own this very popular taco truck
what do i need to do to actually
implement sleek solution to make my
customers experience a little bit better
so we have spent a lot of time to make
sure it is seamless and easy for our
vendors to onboard on a system because
because we are in you know uh trying to
give them as much ease of use as
possible
for you to go to onboard our system you
can sign up on our website or you can
work with one of our channel partner uh
like chromie hungar
once you sign up you'll get an email uh
and in the email you'll have a link link
is very similar to once you click on the
link you will see a permission page very
similar to what you see
uh when you install an android app or
when you uh
click on a facebook app and these are
things um you log in um with your eos
credentials so pos means square clover
toast you know these kind of quantity
systems
and
just give us permission and that's it
voila we're in the system we we get all
the historical data we can predict uh
how long it takes you to you know to
make the burrito
uh and also our stuff we will generate a
qr code and a unique link for uh for
your your restaurant or your your place
and you can place it on your website um
print it out and we'll definitely send
you marketing material for that uh to
give you like an exposure that you can
use um and you can put on google maps
okay it seems very straightforward and
easy to implement
and you mentioned a few use cases
outside of this restaurant industry
right so what other meaningful use cases
you've seen like
sleek solutions being applied for
recently i think a use case that i'm
very excited about and i can personally
correlate to is you know even you could
because you work at google you know you
have these fancy cafeterias uh which
have like a very nice uh you know food
but it's it's always crowded and um
we are working with uh our channel
partner romy hunger to power some of
these um you know commercial catering in
some way so as an employee you can just
reserve your meal you can just say hey i
want a burrito um and voila and uh
and then i can just place the order and
you'll get a text when you can just go
pick it up
uh so you know you need not physically
wait in line and you know kind of like
waste your time uh you can kind of like
enjoy your time with your colleague
and do whatever you want uh so it just
saves a time for you give you like a a
fast pass disney pass kind of service
and uh gives you time back so thank you
um
to help us further with our architecture
conversation
uh tell us a little about the skill of
your operations today and how many
customers usually are using
your solutions on a daily basis so we
are powering uh about eighteen thousand
food trucks uh by our partnership with
our channel partner rumi hunger and
eighteen thousand is a very significant
portion of the footprint industry in the
united states
well that seems a lot to handle daily so
let's then start talking a little bit
about your infrastructure setup and how
do you set up your architecture stack
today to reach such scale on an ongoing
basis so to give some context we are a
very small team we we have 10 employees
um
across engineering and another aspect
and we are like five engineers it's very
very small team and
uh to ha to handle like such a large
scale uh we cannot do everything you
know uh devops provisioning security
there's like so many things going on and
when you're starting you want to focus
on your business uh that's the kind of
philosophy that we have been following
and that is one of the reason we we
chose kubernetes it takes a lot of
complexity order system for us so we can
kind of focus on our business logic and
our core value proposition which is wait
times and those are things so we use
kubernetes and kubernetes takes care of
all the complexities like you know
networking certification setup load
balancing and all those uh you know
the the mission critical thing that you
definitely need in place and you want to
rely on and that's what communities
provide us
all of our business logic sits uh as
like a a stateless part so to say within
kubernetes uh basically a docker image
that we kind of publish
and uh and it is used uh in the
kubernetes as a part we can easily
horizontally scale like uh if we go from
eighteen thousand to like one million we
can you know throw in more parts and
like we scale very easily and that's not
the benefit of communities and actually
we saved uh close to 100k uh from
kubernetes uh in last last one year or
so
which has been like great for us as a
small salary you know
free money is like it's always good
and you know as a philosophy we are
trying to cut down as much as possible
on the devops as i said uh we are using
management services that's where gke
comes in and plays like a great role for
us
uh all the complexities taken care of
it's a first grade citizen within gcp
we can integrate from our um from our
other cloud provider aws so we were on
aws before moving to gcp and some of our
data is still on um a device like we're
using aws with uh cloud cloudfront aws
as a cdn and it works seamlessly
with our pods
and one more dbs database so
i would say very scalable start powered
by multi-cloud and
yeah
it works for us right now
you mentioned a little bit of your
recent migration to dcp so what were the
main technical driving decisions to that
led you to make that decision
so uh we were using kubernetes on aws
like we are using here and uh we started
aws because of uh different reasons um
uh we were using adobe's when we were
not using kubernetes uh we're like when
we're in mvp stage
somehow kubernetes was still i would say
uh
getting into the aws space a lot of
things were missing we had to use
third-party services like
helm and uh and lens um
which is doable when you are using like
massive other aspects like dynamodb but
when you are using
database for just kubernetes and like a
few other things it seemed a bit
overkill and that's where we were
started exploring other aspects like gcp
azure and such
and using gcp it's very native uh
everything is kind of
uh part of the gt i really would have to
use lens or helm and these custom
installing subscripts and such uh either
i can do it from the google cloud
console or like comment and so it works
very good for us and that's one of the
main reason we moved
and obviously like google has its own
benefit of
deep learning vms
uh you know google is known for its own
um
apis we are using google computer vision
apis so there was like also a motivation
for us to move looking at your
infrastructure a lot of the sleek's
magic here comes from the intelligent
infrastructure that you have and the
data
you have running on the edge so could
you talk a little bit about like that
edge component of your infrastructure
definitely so i just want to highlight
why do we need we need edge component
why can't we just you know
get data from point of the system and uh
that should be enough so with point is
the system we get historical data so we
understand that weekend's lunch is gonna
be a busy time friday evening is going
to be time but there are these uh
anomalous events like when you're in a
stadium you don't know when the game is
going to be scheduled it can be on the
weekend but like time can vary or if
you're a bar in front of like the
stadium you will have like once the game
is over a lot of people come in and so
you need to mod all these things and we
cannot ignore these spikes because we
are in the business of giving uh the
right wait time most of the time because
i think i can just say 10 minutes wait
time on average and you should be happy
that's not how it works first we need to
be very accurate that's what we need uh
to be able to figure out wait time on
ground how many people are there and we
have tried computer vision we use
state-of-the-art eulo v4 uh competition
models and even able to do better than
that uh
but the previously was a concern so we
ended up using away propriety technology
where it's like a size of uh like uh i
would say an iphone like
where we have this thing you can plug in
it it detects how many people are in a
vicinity and it can make a different
session in terms of are these people
employees all these people customer
potentially or how long the people are
there so we can get an idea of the foot
traffic and that kind of gives us the
real-time idea of um okay there's an
anonymous even a lot of people walked in
and those are things
and we feed all this data um
in s3 for uh our aws server for long
term um long term storage and again
because we were on aws python but our
currently is being migrated to gcp for
for our model training purposes
so you are leveraging machine learning
models to create a lot of these priority
queues and predictions so could you
expand a little bit more on how you
design this ml pipeline
sure
so we have these uh small iot devices
which gather data and send this
anonymous data
to our services so two types of data
sets are sent to us one type of data set
i would say is the real time that kind
of feeds into our system and is directly
sent out to our uh services running in
in gke so it kind of gives an idea
aggregated how many people are there at
time t and those are things
more advanced data still private uh and
like pretty sensitive data um that we
you know remove any kind of uh
identifiers of things is sent and uh
metallizing s3 aws f3 bucket for us
and it is for archival storage whenever
we want like you know update the model
that move the data to cloud storage
which is on gcp uh this is provide like
a very easy to you know move the data um
scripts and uh pipeline for us so we
just use official stuff for that we use
uh
gcp gpu powered uh deep learning vms um
with pytorch and trainer model uh on
these vms
and you know how the model training
works between different versions of the
model and
push the model configuration to github
to docker and then kind of uh
run a flight experiment
and
gke takes care of all this stuff from
there you know like shipping it is very
easy for us if the matrix looks fine we
can just flip the tire and kind of make
it work great and you're using pi torch
and deep learning vms and which are our
compute engine virtual machines that are
pre-configured with the most popular
machine learning frameworks
so i would i would love to
know a little bit more how that
experience was like for you so uh it's
not that i have python just my favorite
thing um so our expert engineer like who
who's been working with us for some time
he's an expert in pie torch and
being a startup we give you the freedom
to choose how you want to do things so
so that that's how we are in pytarch um
we have not uh seen any kind of
complaints uh and like people are
internally happy it's not it's a second
grade we never felt like that uh
everything's pre-installed there's no
dev dependencies to be handled and
there's no uh issues like that
everything natively negatively
integrates uh with our pipeline even
moving uh cloud was very easy for us uh
for uh when you move from university to
pcp so moving the pipeline has been very
easy for us especially the the migration
from s3 to cloud storage i think that
was the main concern we had but even
even that was very easy for us
thank you guru so to finalize a little
bit our conversation here
there's a lot going on as we saw and so
how do you monitor and everything that
is happening in your and how's your
deployment routine how do you deploy
your applications
our deployment is uh is very much yeah
using kubernetes uh pipelines
um we have all of our code in github uh
after every
vr push um there's a new label created
and our docker image is created
which is uh pushed back to kubernetes on
our flight experiment that runs for some
time um
and then it is updated to uh production
depending on how you know the error rate
and monitoring kind of like uh gives us
any unless there's a bad signal uh it
takes care of and it's being updated
thank you gurov
we just saw how sleek create an ai based
priority lane solution so we can all get
to our food services or any events
quicker
by building the infrastructure on google
cloud they save around a hundred
thousand dollars just last year and by
scaling their serving platform on gke
and training their ml models on pi torch
using our deep learning vms thousands of
retailers now can boost their profits
while improving their own site customer
experience
thanks once more gurav and thanks for
being with us today and for being a
google cloud customer
thanks liberal thanks for having me it
was great chatting with you
if you like this session of architecting
with google cloud please make sure to
hit the like button and also to
subscribe so you can be up to date to
any new upcoming sessions on
architecting solutions on google cloud
platform
thank you